[Music]
Nadeem are you single are you a single
man are you online dating are you
virtually dating on zum-zum know is
there zoom like dating chats no there
isn't but like people on zoom or people
are going on zoom to do this like
FaceTime baby well why don't I just go
on FaceTime I don't know maybe because
they don't want to give their phone
number out oh that's a good reason why
cuz it's not just zoomed you could do it
on Instagram you could do it on whatsapp
you could do it on whatever but you know
like on the Instagram there's a future
where you could just go hi video charge
oh are you dating right now cuz that's
the same questions you ask me they're
not all virtually you of course you are
yeah I got this girl in world of
warcraft she's a orc I'm a human I don't
know if it's really gonna work out cuz
it's like the speech like we're supposed
to battle it out but like we're trying
to make it work right now I'm dating
right now for real I'm single yeah I'm
not so happy when we date okay so
there's this there's this company that
is selling fake muscles and fake boobs
for people oh my god based like online
I got a c-shape I want to see fake
muscles turn digital filter no like a
physical thing that considered
catfishing I know right it's further
catfishing cuz that's the way I actually
see if the person if I'm gonna get
catfished or not it's it's really like
before you even meet someone I think
everyone should video call them mm-hmm
cuz it's like they can't hide that [ __ ]
and they don't have a fair play they can
with these new things will get catfished
these days cuz I'm like but like what
it's a completely different person I'm
like oh we have so much technology
have you watched 90 days yeah say no I
still haven't seen it what do you guys
watch it that's how they get catfished
you'll see yeah it's by TLC but you
could watch it on like YouTube Netflix
who think Amazon you gotta buy it on
Amazon yeah
I don't Eve you could probably like
pouring it somewhere but I'm not illegal
like that so they never plan on meeting
these people then they censor that oh
yeah you're gonna impress them with the
virtual boobs and then you're you make
him fall in love with your personality I
think a lot of guys actually do that in
dating apps we got one friend she like
dates online and she's been like
catfishing in a sense that doesn't match
up with a profile like at least 10 times
I like how guys always lie about their
height like guys always claim that
there's like three inches taller than
they really are
let's say five four and they always use
really old pictures like 10 years prior
it's really weird how they do a group
and like every photos in the group I'm
definitely that more attractive guy do
you have to like go through all the
photos and deduct who's in which one's
constantly knowing like that I'm moving
on there's that many trips online that
people use dude it's so funny so on
tinder I would say more than 50% of the
women on there are just trying to trap
dudes for their premium snap only fans
all these things 50%
ton of girls out there so here's a talk
to me on my snapchat virtual date muscle
suits why don't buy it
yo look at the ABS are on the [ __ ]
chest example like the before and after
example other guys that's kind of dawn
button that sure like that this looks he
doesn't look Buffy just looks puffy
puffy and fluffy
oh my colleague how guys think we want
buff guys wait we don't want our girls
these days they like buff guys now do
this I feel well I can't fit in this but
I feel like most girls like skinny toned
guys I think they like guys with a good
personality I mean there are the some
that do want it that do want a buff dude
but that's like a smaller percentage
well I think you'd definitely attract
someone if you look decently like fit
yeah but not like over-the-top there has
to be a certain type again cuz I look at
how many girls that like Michael B
Jordan right and he's jacked so like if
he was
his face wasn't exactly what he's
attractive but I feel like the two main
factors note is attractive face and
height name a really attractive guy who
is really skinny handsome
no Brad Pitt's jak2 though he was a job
he was like ripped he was ripped but
that's but that's a modern days like
right now because he was skinny not
ripped because he had muscles make
someone who's currently skinny I don't
pay attention Kasey chance he's skinny
because he thinks he's fat I think like
all actors right now our producers
become anyone at the bar Jason Momoa
he's jacked Hey people like Chris Pratt
now and he's not like when did everyone
start liking Chris Pratt when he got
Jack well cuz he was old he was hot well
he wasn't a sex symbol he wasn't sold
that way before because he was chunky
what about Chris Hemsworth personality
in parts and right before this Hemsworth
the shock to they thought you was really
funny after you got everyone like Daniel
day-lewis when he was fast I'm gonna say
Tom Holland but pretty he's kind of
Jackson spider-man movies he's pretty
skinny
it's giddy jacked yeah no J he's skinny
but he's also being marketed tonight 13
year olds cuz he's playing a high
schooler who's that
Ansel Elgort he's the baby driver guy
he's cute I am you're skinny he's skinny
to be sexy are you like wait the point
that we're trying to make those that
we're not looking for muscles first they
just happen to always be to get its face
and height right No so girls so when
they did this study of like what girls
look for in a guy personality face it's
like the looks is not like it's probably
top 5 but it's probably number 4 or 5 on
the priority list but for men it's the
first thing it's a silk shirt is what
they're looking for
it's the confidence that they put out so
they you talked about that's the muscle
yeah that's your biggest muscle the
confidence is the most Jack don't ever
[ __ ] OBO them anymore jack will give
themselves more confidence that's a lot
of Jack so I'm saying if that's you work
on your confidence as a lawful and
right there's fake as [ __ ] and that's
not confidence built confidence is a
homeless man that walks in and [ __ ]
makes out with a girl and he's only got
two teeth that's confidence book as she
might consider dating him because he did
that confidence is the sexiest thing if
the guy had a lot of muscles and was not
confident that's a huge [ __ ] term
yeah I know a lot of people like that
and I'm like oh man
you fraud they look like this
picture perfect man that's ready to
[ __ ] leech it and then they're like
scared even to the ladies do anything
gonna make a decision what about the
boobies though what about the DA's made
the boobies I don't give a [ __ ] about
anything depends of your boobie manner
it new Dean's job keep his options open
I feel like God are way more shallow and
visually stimulated I think so too
I think the reason why your friend even
got catfished so many times and or
forgave them is because she was able to
see past wait
you're not six feet like you said way
better personally she forgave them no
one the same person that she went out
with ten times
[Music]
Mitchell [ __ ] she gets reeled in by
catfish but good for her for not
sticking around yeah you move on it's
like oh [ __ ] you look nothing like what
you said cuz then if they're lying about
that like what the [ __ ] else are they
lying about like literally every could
be lying about their bank account when
they said they had five hundred but they
really have five million I want to be
reversed
catfish where it's an ugly girl and then
you see her she's hotter would you go
out with the girl first no knowing that
she's ugly in your mind like Shallow Hal
oh yeah that makes sense like say you're
super loaded you're the prince of this
thing crazy rich a movie plot no it's uh
nice dad he just he didn't really think
but like imagine you came out like like
Aladdin
well pretty jasmine go down when I talk
to these people right say like you
talked to a guy are you to yourself you
don't want them to know you're famous
you didn't want them to know you're
super rich you want them to like you for
you then you can give them everything
right but otherwise people are just
coming to you because they know you're
what if they like you because you were
poor and now they find out you're rich
and like you fraud [ __ ] you I'm gonna be
with a poor man if you lied about this
one else you're gonna lie about
but they're like well no for that you're
confident about your wealth like a
reverse still [ __ ] up for sure don't
test to me you [ __ ] but I think hurt
Emily I feel like it's the lesser of the
two like if if I got lied to because
they were trying to make sure I wasn't
coming after them for their money like
they're trying to protect themselves is
like there's a better motive okay that's
a better motive because then the other
way is like they're lying because they
just hate themselves or they want to be
this thing that they're not and they're
fooling you that's way worse what the
[ __ ] yeah there's one next you one can
guarantee that they like you for you
yeah if you act like you're poor when
you're rich yeah but if you act like
you're rich when you're poor then you're
just trying to put out something that
they can fall that at least for you
you're saying you're thinking that
they're like you because you're rich
right you know you're literally just
placing yourself in a worse position
because you're not even attracting
someone for you it's like for this
facade that you created this more [ __ ]
up is not sustainable one time I was
hooking up with this girl and in the
whole time I thought she had small
boobies but it was a really tight tube
top in a sports bra thingy and she took
it off and it was really big and I said
oh you lied I'm not gonna suck on these
and I walked away
no be like I just yeah I was so happy oh
oh my god where were you hiding those
things sports bras are funny how was a
gentleman cuz I wasn't looking there I
was looking there sigh it was a mystery
what you were hooking up no before that
during that game has a generator no well
he looked on there little bit nothing oh
I don't know if it's a sports bra it was
just I don't know what it's called I
don't know feminine products but then
when it popped out I was like well then
I didn't turn around and I move in space
I turn around and go you lying [ __ ] how
dare you but she didn't like it's just
you didn't I know guys that when they
losing when a girl takes out her chicken
cutlets and she has small boobs don't be
like you like [ __ ] no guy would ever
say you didn't have you'll have big
titties
oh oh oh not only right after we have
sex this
that's exactly what it is that's other
friends teach you a lesson
yeah but I feel like it's the
billionaire trick it's the same concept
right it's like you get something good
before it's like oh I love your
personality and your [ __ ] rich right
but that's a good catfish it's a reverse
catfish I like those as long as if
you're talking to like a like a guy
right and then you like oh dang he's
packing and then he pulls out the
Kleenex when you guys are already in bed
yeah or or or he was like man that the
hot commodity god I was scared of that
big dick I brought protection or what if
he's like I actually have a small dick
it's so small and you're like it's cool
of you for you and then you get together
your life I don't have a small [ __ ] do
you live in that's weird what else are
you doing about it she wanted to be like
loved for who he is not for it you can
lie down words just don't beat a light
up words no just don't work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]